okay yeah man were some fool podcast
welcome to the Warsaw fool podcast with
Felipe Esparza
Rodrigo Torres right here yeah man
chillin man
it was my birthday happy birthday to me
happy birthday dog
thanks man it's not everyday turn 42 on
IMDB my Hollywood age player yeah man
super excited Brobee said we get it
before we get to all that fun stuff I
went to a cool audition last week hell
yeah last week yeah took a couple of
days ago and actually there was no
audition what's going on here
there was no audition man I can't even
mention it I I feel like I had to send a
release form did I even talk about it
okay that's how secret one audition okay
so he's telling everybody yeah but I
don't even know if I got it but I'm
pretty sure I didn't because I haven't
got a call yet but um looks too close
but all hell yeah at least one up there
and try it out at least I went out there
right like when I was something I will
sit down and watch a movie and then go
you know what I could have been that
blummo just came out of nowhere
oh hell yeah dude I could have been that
truck driver who helped Bruce Willis
give a little history about New York
City in the die hard the silver screen
dog but those roles I noticed that I'm
they're not um they're not open for them
for the for everybody you know like all
the actors like anybody who looks like
me they're not open their callers
specifically for the role they don't
it's not like I like when I go for now
come audition for a commercial and
they're like coping common people who
look like me they don't they don't cry
everybody bro so they it's narrowed down
to a full people it's gonna fit that
they kind of want to see on that I felt
good though cuz I was there reading with
the same people I read for like another
role for that movie with Will Smith
focus okay
so looking for that for that Arab
looking long hair guy swarthy swarthy
yeah
so yeah but I saw up I was there reading
with big spider or little spider or
medium spider from five from Friday
after next Jacob Marcus no logical bark
is it little
Rollo Rallo yeah because then we'll
spider little spider and meaning spider
you cut in the web dog [ __ ] did you in
the loop dog I'm in the loop gotta give
it a little give it a look I'm a bad
mother give it a little give it a look
oh yeah genius
give me the loop give me the loop I'm a
bad mother
I've been rubber [ __ ] said the
slave ships with the stain for five
something says the mother I let it die
mama thinks she a superstar
taking gold change to [ __ ] I forgot that
[ __ ] beliefs a pump that [ __ ] nasty dog
ready to die what's up fool man Kelly
what's what people still to us that
we're in California
[ __ ] you know Congress did allow it
we'd be more government and it's funny
do the Republican dude propose that [ __ ]
out of over there were alien air in
Temecula but like a couple years back
but it's like the whole thing of the GOP
is less government right ain't gonna
make more government with another state
I know but they want they want rich
people to go to that state what poor
people would be stuck in everyone
everywhere you can't get rid of poor
people man you keep on pissing out
homeless people are gonna keep on
starting fires and [ __ ] I can't have
[ __ ] you won't either
you can't be care about get away from
poor people mad cuz you know what and
you can't get away from anybody because
it's in like I think human nature
brought to be adventurous and seek our
new lab oh no man bro like you'll be
living a river statue you're 80 bro no I
don't see myself living right now this
is what's happening right now Bo your
pops is ok with that huh do my daddy
ain't going anywhere doc they're there
forever
they're like a nail in in in in the
coffin of this history is adventure this
does not an allergy dude he doesn't have
any adventure doc he didn't even want to
go to Mexico dawg he was kicking and
screaming you tell them but he was all
dude who like ba Baracus on the 80 with
a plate huh do they do they're all they
do is do what
do and that's it go to sleep at a
certain time eat at a certain my dad 68
he doesn't he doesn't but he won't stop
he cuz right now just finish up building
the house but he doesn't stop but he
doesn't want to do anything out of his
routine he doesn't want to be in
anybody's car he doesn't want to be on
anybody schedule
none of that [ __ ] he'll meet you there
though sorry this is exactly like Joe
Diaz complains about everything fool
like fool he and having a dog but that
he said in his wasteful he he does not
like to travel dog does not like to hop
on planes no trains nothing dog doesn't
like to wait in line in the stores dude
old school fool some of this
[ __ ] would not air B&B he'll be
like [ __ ] that I don't want to walk us
somebody on his floor although my feet
that too and he salsa says he can't get
any sleep when he sleeps in hotel beds
he cannot sleep he can only sleep in his
bed
Faline ever been tired no you couldn't
yeah but he's not into that [ __ ] dog
they're not open to that [ __ ] that fools
I did I made your stupid ass you're not
gonna tell me [ __ ] [ __ ] out of here yeah
dude and into that [ __ ] still complains
dogs always with my mom all the time
same [ __ ] I knew somebody broke that
their dad has never been to a delay him
but to Ally once probably to get a
passport and I was it that was it he
never went back then never had Chinese
food hates Chinese food because he was a
a Korean War veteran goddamn dude
where was he what do they live at
Ontario and that's all he's home from
Mexico to Ontario no he was born in
America even worse but but I grew up in
that area but never went to LA damn dog
who see that's what I feel matter from
Mexico dog but he came over here when he
was like 1415 dog like like we live in a
big city man so we don't really have to
go that far for far like there's no way
somebody dragged me to Paris California
I don't know how people who live that
far or or just live in the city of
Commerce which is like 48 minutes from
here in every life they never leave that
area like they don't know [ __ ] about no
hopping on the 101 no
and taking a drive in Santa Barbara or
or go to the Comedy Store or to
Hollywood like to them they got a plan
that [ __ ] out oh hell yeah that's a big
old mean trip dawg
that's a trip man mmm but I wanted to do
where our guest brought he's already
here sort of early like a sow with
Skylar stoned bro welcome brother what's
going on chillin man he was a cook
awaiting brother of you saw me with a
cook brewery put so he put something his
crotch you know that will be waiting no
no no we watch it at your pad one day
yeah and I scratch my head and all the
dandruff falls on garlic salt my crazy
to hope well is it any trade when that
movie to wait II know you think Anna
Guzman part 3 Mike Oh Mike sup you look
at Mike I know I look just like straight
up white boy is Mike Rowe Tom one of the
consideration consideration oh yeah oh
my god dude doesn't wake up for your
consideration bro with Eugene Levy and
all the food from the other movies
Christopher guest's and there are it's a
it's a spoof on being nominated for an
Oscar or or the hype behind the Oscar
and he was like the one of the DJs in
the morning with and these girls trying
to be all like an artist and it was our
talking like morning old-school morning
he's like the Red Bull brother that's
how I started like I started as a DJ's
intern and so I just had to sit through
all sorts of like morning shows that
were just like 103.9 and wwl G coming up
next we've got you know Felipe Esparza
like and they bring guests on and then
the guest would always have a look on
their face of like what is happening
right now like because there was no
realness to it like you guys are talking
like real right right but imagine if it
came you look Skyler's to the studio how
you doing tell us about your project
that's total morning radio we waiting
people robo like like power 106 with a
cowbell yeah this Fool has a voice like
a strip club DJ
I get that a lot you know who was a
strip club DJ was
Josh Adam Meyers yeah he was just here
man and so was our mom now all together
we had here from Silicon Valley Oh Jimmy
Oh yang Jimmy Oh yang y-yeah I can't see
that at all yeah yeah no no I couldn't
see him as a DVD to the triplets we did
the boys come on guys let's take out
those crumble dollar he was talking
about his job was to get the strippers
to come out because sometimes they
didn't want to come out for their Wow so
the furniture went pop what's up full
podcast these guys are drawing up
strippers they just did a pregnancy test
backstage in a bad mood don't want to
come out you know a status and funniest
thing I ever saw what's that it was a
bunch of stripper with a meme and they
all I was like 10 of Umbro them they
were all holding hands and they were all
praying before they start stripping they
weren't gonna circle at this Jew Jesus
we were about to pop all their lingerie
I've never been a big strip club guy
every week there right no oh
someone said that I sounded like okay
it's never been my thing I don't know
[ __ ] well you never what do I do the
day I turned 18 I went and I think I
liked it oh yeah then I got to LA and it
just seemed I don't know I always felt
like I was gonna get hustled like I know
myself
oh that's happening if some girl told me
like a story like in a head just wanna
you know I'm really hit our times I'd be
like okay you want to go to my ATM or do
you mean your daughter raised how can I
help and I just I never wanted to get
conned like that you know did you worry
everything to the strip club so we like
to remember the first time I watch one
strip or the first time I want to play
with her with naked chicks
I've done before with Mexico or oh the
first time bra was a little kid though
we know how parents are Avon and my mom
was so Kris like remember crystal
promotions I like China Avon food I was
at my dad's house
another southern bro our lounger a party
broke out dog are you serious yes and
this lady was studying lingerie or 99
gowns for all these women that were
there but I'm like a bad show you know
let the WIMP and it was like there were
not models you know yeah I think my mom
owns luxury exactly yeah I stopped my
aunt's cousin right there my neighbor's
hot my neighbors mom in lingerie walking
around you know hello Louis Leakey
Ojakian and it was to attend in Spanish
you know like this over here it comes
from line and [ __ ] from France and this
is that no more 1839 you can wear this
but other than Spanish is to do well
next to the world looking at one buddy
she'd be very poor hearing about it over
this was she had like karma
she had a saying for every clothes like
like that guy from Stein from mr. Peter
Smith whatever name is J Peterman J
Peterman
oh yeah J Peterman clothes when you're
out there in the outdoors spaceship
cashmere jacket it's the way to go
something like that she was the sales
lady so late yeah Wow after that hairy
leg strip club what do I went to Mexico
when I was working a dog I was working
at San Diego with some dudes selling
souvenirs during our air show mm-hmm so
we all went to Mexico and we were at a
strip bar there but then we left real
fast I get to see nobody naked and then
and it was I think I was with Irene bro
I went to Bob's classy lady in the
valley I don't know that one but again I
don't know the LA ones well Kalamazoo I
got you covered
I know the cow juice xxx you know the
Phoenix no actually I cannot live in
Venus swinger town over there yeah no
dude places like Phoenix at Vegas
depress me I can't be somewhere with
extreme heat like I could never live in
horrible you walk out you just don't
even feel I don't know you just feel
like a little insect being burned by
that I can't do it I'm not in
impressive yeah imagine broken ribs you
go to an interview you took a shower you
go outside a hardened 20 I can't omit
but you kind of live close to that we
have to have AC on all the time and from
your house to your car to your job and
like there's just a seat constantly and
you don't ever get to feel what it's
like out in the real world yeah I eat
temperatures are just like the San
Fernando Valley dude yeah but you get
really good restaurant deals when you're
like if I am and Phoenix didn't stand up
like I've just noticed that they're
happy hours are like longer because
they're like please come out we know you
don't like to come out but talk to and
6c already mean like they'll try to get
you out you have two comics over there
in a free that's like chuck Bartowski I
can't send the heat oh my god it's too
bad oh I think it would've died Philippe
please turn the first fine soup in Tempe
bar food town and he's like that sounds
like an academy award-winning short film
like Fred Stoller looks for soup and
Phoenix Sun a friend of any friend in
soup that's like an art film if I ever
heard of and there's I'm depressed for
22 minutes and he never finds it shoots
himself at the end and then and then
like the the drama would be him in the
green room when that Mexican who showed
up and started adding Seinfeld him over
and over recognized him from saying and
when I come on to the meeting greed
outside so this guy started banging the
door start come on homie come outside
homie we want to meet you dude it is
funny though I can't I will say this the
only ethnicity that yells credits
instead of like your name is Hispanic
people I'm black I went to rehab last
summer in Mexico and what the heck is
that town Rosarito oh wow yeah I've
heard that about them there is because
it's a it's a well it's a controversial
way of getting sober you basically go do
psychedelics to get sober I was hiding
ibogaine Iowa
yeah but I was down there and I'm where
we've got a shopping day and they took
us out to those little you know markets
and we're like you know buying stupid
little things and whatever buy in
tchotchkes and all the sudden this guy
goes hostile three and I heard it
there's no way he's talking to me the
hostile three to kiss committee hug
because I just watched that fool and
like he thought God next to me takes
pictures with me I did it was it was
pretty funny dude a star came to
Rosarito yeah oh dude he treated me like
I was Tom Cruise I grow I'm not that big
deal man you need to calm the [ __ ] down
I went to the house and got the whole
meal - man always like it's cool away
when you get recognized like that from
one thing you know like hey whatever
Netflix you know the Netflix right but
then like a little gather in any kind of
like weird in which I'm calling
everybody around but no they don't know
what the [ __ ] he's taught what he's
talking about
come on man that's great yeah okay then
I really like in a way they're happy for
their friend but throw the tents gonna
shut up you know you know okay we don't
know he is yeah we have Netflix but what
the [ __ ] and then you as an artist go on
a [ __ ] name the special you
piece of [ __ ]
never there's time that fool will open
up a phone and look for it bro that's
the words oh yeah or how about the guy
that's actually the guy that recognized
you and then the guy next to him doesn't
really a passive-aggressive move where
he just goes like obviously you're a big
deal he's freaking out but I have no
idea the [ __ ] you are oh yeah always the
straight up guy oh you're so cool
there's what you know like dude so tell
me what you've been in what am I
supposed to do like read off my IMDB
right I can roll call the credits over
here yeah or tell me a joke - I started
to read it I started to go raising Hope
and they look know what else I'm like
hostile right now never am i okay I'm
not doing this right tell me what I saw
you it yeah those are weird man
and then you get those mobile games like
start hating on your ass right away too
bad yeah yeah like I'm funny too and you
ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy sucks yeah and
then people always assume because you
work to someone that you were
automatically best friend to them call
him right now
call him
yeah people be like Ryan Reynolds man ho
you guys hang out I'm like bro I worked
with Ryan three days
they don't he's got better things to
think about like sex with Scarlett
Johansson's disease man hey now he has
sex with what's her leg like yeah I
think he's forgotten all about safe to
say or what-have-you did one of you
actually pictures of me during sex with
him that'd be crazy or the radio would
be like probably doesn't happen radio
guys is marked I will bring up something
at that [ __ ] yeah they have no clue
what's going on happy yeah man we're
live in this morning Yakima and we're
here with hostel three yeah
then everybody lose muscle yeah this
hospital - yeah yeah and then I'll get
also people that try and act like
they've seen me in something that I know
they didn't because there's certain
things on my on TV that I was cut out of
so like through it I loved you and rules
of attraction and I'm just like well I
was cut out of that movie so I don't
know like how you loved me in that movie
your spirit of Schuyler yeah exactly
yeah man was some fool Tory about how
would that show last night bro it was
killer dog
who's there it was me Martin Rizzo and
Flaco the only thing was that Flaco was
a little bit under the weather weather
he came over here with a little neck
apparatus I told him fool you should
have told him so he did it sitting down
but he got through his set and it was
cool man he did about 30 minutes it was
yeah oh he's uh you know kind of
flatlines every now and again and we had
a mint flatlines on stage like before
our fans Marvin has mad migraine and the
other heart to write either funny comic
you just said he had a heart like did
they take it out yeah used to have a
heart I usually have heart conditions
but he has a heart condition he had a
pacemaker put in when he was a kid and
then he just had a heart valve replaced
hold it he's 30 a few other Star Wars
he'll be generous tedious
basically he talked about this [ __ ] on
stage kinda he talks about it in like
podcasts and stuff but yeah he's been
honest about it that's pretty cool it's
not much of his material he talks about
being skinny that's naturally part of
the sim just the symptoms is that you
have long skinny fingers and legs can I
get this thing do you lose weight I
don't know if you love skinny man we had
a barbecue net it was my birthday last
outing happy birthday Perez was there
bro birthday slight dick any shoulder
with a wonderful pocket t-shirt on a
guest spot and full we were in a
swimming pool Marty took off his shoes
and he gets in the big old Tony for his
total a baby Groot it's totally a
[ __ ] Groot Groot guardian and
galaxies put your suit
where was this show Riverside oh yeah my
show it's called viva los jokes dude we
were gonna do it again and on July 10th
and yeah it was cool dude oh shut up he
did his time I did give Gracie a guest
spot that band sucked the world played
played a little bit before and then yeah
they had a little in the back yeah it
was cool though dude it was all like on
the Latino tip but it all worked out
dude [ __ ] we got their [ __ ] it's
like 7:30 nobody's airdog and 8:30 the
compact that's always scary huh yeah I
do do we [ __ ] up had a saw this tellers
also and I text a fool Brooke I don't
know where the heck I was where my
Holland Drive broke down and I text the
man this fool said what scared the [ __ ]
out of me because I thought he'd like
every comic was texting me the first
four comics had all text me within five
minutes saying they were running late
I'm like it's a tag-team show so there's
no hose no and someone's onstage they
think they're bringing someone up that
turns into a [ __ ] nightmare
link breaks any was he was early but he
may be he's gonna be well I told him
because I I hit traffic when we right
when we got on Mulholland Drive so I was
or they go they sorry Laurel Canyon
sorry Laurel Canyon there's no way out
yeah so I said I said text Skylar tell
him we're on our way but we're gonna be
there act on at 8:45 or whatever but you
didn't tell him a time you just said I'm
running late that's what I'm saying and
then I was like telling the time he did
write you back some sweating bullets
good oh my god Felipe I'm gonna [ __ ]
murder would be there at you know why it
was bad it was Hollywood bull traffic
because every comic gave me up and said
I'm running late and that you just don't
want that when this show's starting at
like oh that's fun you do Marc Brown was
there and that fool from super troopers
two and one oh hell yeah
hilarious bro dustin ybarra showed up
with your friends we were backstage and
you know we're all hanging out you know
and then the dude from super troopers
showed up and then like a man loved your
movie he said thank you
i fully remodeled to me sorry Roboto bro
and following a bit of comedian of
anything older said it was no Raymond
guy I love cookie and then dustin ybarra
shows dog he's telling the lies for a
long time then he starts talking to that
guy from super troopers the super
excited whoa whoa and hugging them and
this is that then I say man introduce
yourself at least I'm off backstage spit
on it dawg they were three T's together
right but that's another level bro
that's another level see there's the
level of a fan
recognizing you and I know where the
[ __ ] you been at but Dustin was at the
level of working with a bigger an actor
and the actor has to figure out what
movie he worked with you on yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] my absolutely I ran into
people and like they're I know they're
just looking at me like I think we knew
each other and I always throw it out
quicker I don't want it to be [ __ ]
you know get awkward you know that'd be
weird house fever's to go what's up yeah
I don't know who you are
you roundhouse me
I booked a [ __ ] boosting up my head
in it mark for death yeah Mark Wahlberg
you jerked off in front of me in Boogie
Nights you don't number that I was in
the truck in mark I was there when you
[ __ ] peanut I've been to means man
for no reason you can eyes awkward on em
boy boy bro right away by me you do
you're a big fan boy you have no qualms
no serious I if I see famous people
after they owe me I was but you always
know anybody who I went to everybody who
are dedicated hour and a half for the
movie yeah for you over at least two
minutes
I googled your net worth it's 15 million
I'm part of that I made that happy a
bowl in your house dude well you want to
be making you want to be famous and then
you make it I don't want to be left
alone I spend I've seen other movies I
spent 12 hours watching you yeah I can't
have [ __ ] short [ __ ]
I can't wait to bear hug that fool dog
dude yes Tom I turned my head when you
went crazy I still bought a ticket to
the mummy you owe me yeah but I also
think that like when you go up to
somebody and you can name that specific
scene the specific thing he did that
it's cool dog but not just a fan out cuz
you the person famous for watching the
[ __ ] Nutcracker bro I don't know what
whose name was and I went to look for
that [ __ ] okay there's more
from the bill dirty movies I've seen we
saw an American Horror Story it was
American Horror Story I don't wonder
yeah I'll ask man
so I googled his name and I knew his
first and last name Annette and I
mentioned the name John whatever last
name
perfect you know I'm a big fan then
instead of saying
accent man and all the other [ __ ]
yeah well happy bro that's what I'm
doing with his family watching perfor
and I know how it feels but to be an
actor or a comedian watch another
comedian or an actor watch another actor
you don't a [ __ ] either so when I
realize a neighborhood say aftermath
afterwards he was all happy though oh
dude and he said my name do you remember
that one time we were at Hollywood lanes
dude late at night dude and [ __ ]
we're just chilling there and then about
the corner of your eye you caught Vince
Vaughn slipping and then you hit him
with the little line from [ __ ]
swingers and all that [ __ ] was cool I
was walking there with to chase that
were shorter than his daughter you know
super tall dude anyway Christmas lights
yeah yeah it was all during lights right
before the holidays hit Norwood I made I
made a man yeah they're like best
friends actually met Vince through I met
Vince Vaughn is my number one impression
that I do to a stage I'm a baby right
now we're just hanging out care about
this right now right now listen baby I
could use a couple snacks where the
[ __ ] snacks at in this [ __ ] all
right
why do you be Boy George do you want to
hurt me want to make me cry probably not
so I've been doing that for years and
like I'll get doubled like I've been
doing that impression in a long time and
so all comedians know that I do it and
so Steve Byrne and Owen Benjamin and
Ahmed had grabbed me at The Improv once
a few years ago and they just said you
know hey man we have a surprise for you
because they know he's my idol and so he
was upstairs and they took me like
upstairs and he was sitting at dude I
thought I was meeting the Godfather
they're like assuring me to a table and
here's tall [ __ ] Vince Vaughn with a
light over him like an introduction
don't do it it was amazing and so we sat
down and Steve Byrne put me on the spot
he goes he goes hey he goes Ben sound if
you know this but Skylar does an
impression of you oh I love to hear that
and I was like I'm like sitting there
and I didn't know what to do but I knew
that I was on next on stage I go you
know I do it on stage I go why don't you
just come watch my set and I'll do it on
stage he's like I love to so he comes
downstairs
my wife has no idea this has happened
she's already inside she was taping a
set for me for cone and I was trying to
get a appearance on there and so she had
her phone and she's on the side of the
stage and she's filming I get called the
stage Vince Vaughn ends up behind her
she has no idea
Vince Vaughn is behind her and I have
the tape to prove this story she's
filming me and all of a sudden I start
doing Vince Vaughn and she can hear
Vince Vaughn laughing at me doing Vince
Vaughn and that
turns around goes oh my god you're Vince
Vaughn and you can hear that like on the
tape as she's saving me and then I get
offstage it was like the most like
hilarious experience ever it was pretty
[ __ ] awesome I never did know that's
an obscure I try and find people like
you know I don't want to do like Arnold
Schwarzenegger or Jay Leno same one that
everybody does 20 comedians do that same
when I do Arnold Schwarzenegger in the
box what you do what this would be the
San Antonio community you should do are
those who are [ __ ] stuck inside a box
there are people that get away with
doing like ones everyone do like who's
what's-his-name Hispanic comedian help
me out
Pablo doesn't it's [ __ ] great I don't
care what's ahead what yeah that shit's
great yeah what he does is great you
know you can't [ __ ] with that food no
[ __ ] t-shirt I'm gay too the way you
said that was really good and then he
this boy always puts me on the spot
[ __ ] like even like with the Joe Diaz
and president I do it so much don't
weigh those [ __ ] t-shirt on my show
first thing right I'm gonna [ __ ] with
you from the Apple is Kalamazoo why use
this bomb not loaded I'm supposed to
meet that night who and [ __ ] in like
four minutes you send alle copter
prepare the hummus [ __ ] it's like
I still it's like [ __ ] do you don't I
cook somebody muhfuckas do it now that
yeah but it's like I gotta bring it back
I've never heard anybody Joe Diaz Joey
yeah it was an impression I was like
2009 but it's on YouTube still but ya
know he gave it up to me and he gave it
up to me on his podcast but it's uh it's
kind of like you know it's their little
version of it over there so everybody
you know praises over there which is
cool I mean don't get me wrong I'm on
the periphery [ __ ] I'm just
waiting for another [ __ ] introduction
I'm saying
Vince Vaughn styler mode but yeah I love
Coco all day long Coco's the man I love
you in [ __ ] swing this woman was
[ __ ] slapping these [ __ ] you know
I'm saying I mean when they said Coco
was coming out on that Coco is out all
right don't talk about the Pixar Coco's
been talking about that Coco's better
absolutely brown
in Havana 1950 whatever-the-fuck you
know I'm saying foreskin and everything
and I'm saying
the Cuban eggroll is back you know who
that is no should we let it out of what
do I know this person you've heard
yourself bro comedian yeah dude hold on
hold on hold on hold on
Latino oh my gosh this is really
bothering me like I feel like I want to
give you 20 bucks if you guess who that
is a birthday gift from Rodrigo he gave
me this t-shirt and it has our old
friend
oh Willy big Doug what's up bro what's
going on bro you over there in hollywood
hobro you're shining up bro I mean I
guess that's what you could call it I
mean I don't even know what that means
it means doing well bro for yourself I
mean I hear you're doing well hey I'm
all right why are you doing pretty well
on the Inland Empire that's for sure hey
bro sometimes we got to stick to your
own provinces bro
like right now I'm k13 your 909 it
doesn't [ __ ] matter nine five one bro
yeah same thing big era bro hey bro
sometimes you gotta teach these young
guns what's going on bro got have got to
show him some love broke get him under
your wing bro so he says bro allotted a
bro he was the first brought like dude
everybody's broke bro he was a first bro
dude even even more than bros like you
know them with the big trucks [ __ ]
motorcycle let's let's go first bro is
probably probably sure he was saying bro
and that was bloody no but bro bro but I
think Willy was before dude Willy even
was doing bro in the disco days I
believe who took bro to the to the next
level like I'm like like Teddy Roosevelt
movies I was [ __ ]
what's his name was it that a sketch
well Paul Rudd was doing it with
what's-his-face in the I Love You Man I
think aren't they doing oh they did it
movie bro Manson and then I feel like
the second Sean William Scott movie they
did it to like a just all those brony
movies right right
there's no Chris Dorian bro hey bro hey
bruh little brows bro a little brain
area bro five foot two bros bro from
another Canadian Chris Tory he withdrew
the bros hold me hold me bro he's my bro
bro bro he's everybody's bro bro who
does this Chris Doering Brad from the
Bay Area that's the Bay Area hippy bro
though yes it's a Grateful Dead bro it's
like peace and love bro that's what that
kind of warriors bro mark Serritella
no no used to book comedy jokes bro oh
he's hey bro max hairy Tala here like
when he leaves you have lights on
outside hey Skylar
mark sorry Tala later bro better bruh
little bro tiny there's a Tommy T bro
work with me brother
I hate it when someone texts to me bro
like it begins a taxibro like bro I said
I'll be there like it's like dude don't
bro me and it sags I know it comes from
you bro
I have a guy who directed Felipe special
a brother no he texts me and says hey
girl
yeah and I do not respond come hug it
frat boy okay that's not acceptable
would you write back if it was my
girlfriend I would I would write back
but if it's a dude hey girl
that's not do target a favor he's trying
to get a favor oh that's a favor attack
yeah hey girl
don't you ever Laker connect you know
yeah hey girl you know subliminal
messages bro by the way I'm never not
starting an email at least from now on
without hey girl
what did you stab them Factory the first
time I got on stage was 1998 at a at a
pub in Kalamazoo and my first joke is
really bad would you like to hear yeah
yeah my first joke was so I go to WMU
yeah you guys might know that is Western
Michigan University but if you really
know but you know for me it stands for
weed Miller Lite uterus I think my
friends that were there were like yeah a
four I think I bailed it two minutes oh
really you give me a buzz character I
mean you gotta give me like a bro you
gotta give me credit though it was not a
stand-up show it was a true mic with
poetry and saucy that's when it's [ __ ]
hits the wall dog yeah acoustic [ __ ] I
think it was a situation and made you
creative for that joke I mean you think
of that joke yeah yeah back then dears
they were loud joke did you go to a lot
of just that one time I think I maybe
did it the first three or four times
because they open up a comedy club
directly across the street after that
and I tried it there and I got a good
couple sets all I did it the purse was
act out so it was all act outs there
were no jokes it was just like setup and
then something physical I really like
sort of my first joke bad I do I found a
box of a shoebox of this I you know
these are old sets they remember mini DV
cam sore the little tapes I miss the
bond is where the mini tape mini tapes I
love those man yeah and I've got 20 of
them and like they're all sets and I'm
like oh my god do I pull this out or not
it might be fun to put some on line
though you know oh man I have this
horrible joke about Romeo and Juliet if
Romeo was a crackhead and he was trying
to get back into the castle all cracked
out it was like an act out then yeah act
out bro yeah you know we're gonna
this like Oh Julia can't find my pipe
you know like act out with the face you
know all coked out and looking for stuff
on the floor it was horrible man I was
about to give you props in front of a
warning but it was a horrible one-man
show a lot of acting bro horrible acting
that keeps going over over and over and
they they was not Maria at that of Julia
yeah it was you know at that time it was
like 1998 and so dane hadn't blown up
stand-up hadn't blown up it was like
there's a weird time for stand-up like
if you were a stand-up fan you were just
part of like a small club there was
nothing like this there was no all
things comedy podcasts you only mean
people like Tom Segura selling out
theaters without having like huge TV and
movie credits or hosting us and it's a
night show there yeah it was so
different a little bit of a Comedy
Central at that time yeah but but also
again it was like a weird Network it was
not enough of the love-master yeah yes
Comedy Central didn't blow up till after
Chappelle you could Park of course Joe
had cops that stand-up comedy show but
they were not like now they were just
bunch of them yeah but you half-hour
leave the game you had a bunch of Pepsi
the Rideau shows yeah the PepsiCo stand
up the improv that's all I was around
back then and I remember and when I was
in college they had that certs they had
a certs thing where they were going
around the college's I remember that
sponsoring these comedy shows trying to
find it wasn't really Stan of German yet
it was like hey so we have South Park we
had the daily show and that's what we
are and then like Dane and Patton and a
tell and a lot of guys kind of brought
it back I mean really you got to give
the credit to Dana Dane didn't blow up I
don't think we'd be seeing Jeff Dunham
on the Comedy Central - and they will
have the only lay wheels calmly Travel
Show at the time yeah come on a bit man
she'll show who's the first one to blow
up Austin social moment you come to LA
well I basically had
contact my dad was college roommates
with a guy that produced rescue 9-1-1
you remember that show yeah yeah and so
my whole life I had heard about my dad's
you know college roommate and like we'd
watch her skinny one and his name would
be in the credits so he became like I he
became like this big figure to me
same gym millio and he said hey I've got
a job and he goes it's five hundred a
week you can stay on my in my guesthouse
for like the first couple months but
then you got to get your own place and
come on out I couldn't pass it up didn't
[ __ ] no I remember
in 98 dog know that nose 98 was my first
stand-up this was 2000 this would have
been September like no good [ __ ] yeah it
was no I was very fortunate I mean I was
a piece of [ __ ] employee and I got fired
very quickly but you know should have
called me though it was the week that
the Matt marshal model it was the week
Marshall Mathers album came out so I
drove out here listening to that whole
album just all psyched ins gripping the
wheel and yeah yeah 83 blue Volvo
breaking down the hallway and I mobile
yeah 240 yeah with a four-door they have
of those things this one was two door
okay I had a two door at that time you
got that one I had to I had a Bobo - you
did and with uh an under wagon it was a
gray
Bauval the 80 88 three to forty four
door yes know that yeah we've only
driven Volvo's in my family I've driven
six myself now it's a first timer that I
don't know Volvo's right now but yeah
I've had three really and I have a
station where I know for sale for sale
yeah dude Volvo's of the safest car
you're ever gonna drive in yet their
[ __ ] tank student saved my life I got
hit by a drunk driver once I be the EMT
came to visit me that they cut me out of
the you know out of the car instead of
the life yeah he came and said he goes
if you weren't involved you'd be dead
and so I never stopped driving ball was
out to that I was like okay feels the
one we have the wagon it feels like I'm
driving a safari truck like it's a
little abrasive water line those cars
yeah that's for sure
yeah it
the way you know that your neighbor has
a Volvo is you just hear it like you
hear that whistle oh yeah mucho la and
you you gotta fight for this job so what
you do next got fired very quickly I did
some extra work and on the set of Van
Wilder the director while Becker liked
my just feel and vibe and and he put me
front and center and a Ryan Reynolds
scene I've done like three movies with
Ryan and still doesn't know him
or again he might picture me during sex
we don't know we have we went out to
check in with him but I was a little
alien Bruin Green Lantern what was it
like man like you you were like excited
to do extra work at the time very good I
was too bro very I thought that you
maybe I had to dream grow up every X job
first actor that ever work that start
we're gonna pluck me out and put me a
give me lines just like a scatter stone
yeah I would get on set and I say this
to people so there's anybody even out
there the team thing about doing this
doing extra work is a lot like going to
film school and people laugh at me but
dude you get on set and you really learn
how [ __ ] is really done if you pay
attention yeah if you're paying
attention and I thought I did I [ __ ]
so everybody talked to you you answer
except the main actors and the director
but you pretty much talk to everybody
see but I I crossed that line I found
ways up to those people and I knew like
I didn't do it in like a in a snaky way
where you big oh my god this guy's on it
you know yeah I got coke blink twice if
you needed blink twice third wing yeah I
wasn't that bad back then when I got
here I did not have a drug my drug
problem hit about oh six that's when she
got better right me too
yeah I went with nuts bro that no six
yeah it was bad I'm I party with people
that party with you but funny you and I
never got a hold each other which i
think is so strange strange because we
were crossed paths all the time and and
then I remember around these to be this
one kid who passed away and he was he
was a Gallic hook wheel with my drug
connection in Hollywood because I had a
drug connection everywhere else and but
they have the Hollywood scene
and he'll go with a guy and I don't
wanna say it's full name but he was show
up to wherever I was with a [ __ ] um
with a [ __ ] fishing tackle box
wait hold on a second they you know my
dealer oh my gosh how we never talked
about this before
cuz that we know cuz you know what about
addicts is that out once we sober up to
see another guy that we know party with
the same person makes me feel sick a
little bit I feel like seeing jacket
exactly right exactly right
check on the box is delicious at 2:30 in
the morning but I want to see
jack-in-the-box at 4:00
oh god I puke no I had a friend if I
know him he wasn't it you the East
Indian guy comedian who passed away from
the Laugh Factory young guy what's name
I forgot a name either one I hooked me
with that connection so we're done with
the same guy yeah you know my weird
that's great that sounds like a reality
show whoo you know my dealers okay he
used to be on the southside of La
Cienega
you wore a dumb beret cuz he thought it
was cool when I was at your show and I
realized how packed it was you know how
you show that we are well sold out and
I'm and I saw the lineup and then I
started thinking about if I would do a
comedy just as long as some of these
guys here who are big huge stars you
know Marc Maron then cook I started like
in 96 and I was thinking so I went up on
stage first thing that came out was
honesty yeah so I've been doing this a
long time and I realized that the more
the longer I do it and and the less
famous and busy I get I realize I have
more drug dealers numbers yeah I had to
do a purge in my phone because I had
some people in there that shouldn't be
in there and you know when this is done
I'll tell you I don't you know what
happened to that fool but dude it's not
not pretty no no no no no no no no it's
bad it's bad so but it was a soldier
this guy drug dealers usually are
this hat was so well bro like I don't
like this I will call this guy out of
nowhere
two three in the morning he'll show up
where I was I was that as long as I'm in
the Hollywood area right and I'm I don't
want to help in that [ __ ] you know that
our fishing tackle box
yep and mount this watering right now
[Laughter]
everything whatever what time bro I
bought our about coke from him about
weed and I bought a viagra
okay now I know you know him because
that was his thing that was such a [ __ ]
like you know if you're like I'm gonna
beat up some you know if you're at the
movie theater you draw up by medium
popcorn they're always go would you like
a large for 25 cents more
that was his move dude I'd be like yo
let me get a pack of percocet so I'll
take for zani bars let me get an ounce
of weed a half a gram of coke and like
you know I I didn't want a viagra
remember him talk like that like you're
getting it a viagra I'm like why I don't
have a problem is that you don't have to
have a problem it's awesome
he's just trying to sell me a long boner
like you know just because he was in
Hollywood he also wanted to talk like he
was in Hollywood
ya know who came back from he loved
named I just got the whole house of weed
yeah
I hope you like I was just part sorry
I'm so tired I was in Marilyn Manson's
house all night yeah sitting on the
couch not bothering nobody probably yeah
I'm just trying to think of people that
he would name drop that like I feel like
that are publicly known like I talked
about yeah if there's a couple that I
know people don't know they do drugs I'm
not Martin are you being serious
no okay cuz that would be really funny
no Ricky Martin assistant used to go buy
weed at a place where I could go buy
weed at another comics house dude he
dealt it every Fairfax I couldn't
believe how many people this guy dealt
but it wasn't leave it like it's like um
this guy is like lay calm he's working
like like like a futuristic drug dealer
like
he knows how to like I don't know you
know it's like it's like if I were to
give his phone number of somebody he
wouldn't know that that person that I
gave my phone number to a legit like hey
I'm heating crazy cuz I'm crazy he's on
his P's and Q's P's and Q's yeah I don't
know what happened to him I'll tell you
not here though you're on earth but he's
not here now I need a lot of dealers
like that that's the one who I had two
guys I had tackle box so and so we're
just calm talk box T it was alliteration
for sure but tackle box T and in Mexico
Mike those are my two guys oh my Mexico
Mike yeah Mexico Mike was had more rules
Mexico Mike was he would you could never
go wherever Todd was dumb okay I'm sorry
anyway so-and-so was dumb he would let
you come to his house and he didn't have
like he didn't look out the window as he
didn't ask questions you could show up
with three people at least this is my
experience I don't know if these this
way with you I could bring anybody over
he never asks a question and that's a
really dumb way to do that for a living
really control that [ __ ] so it scared me
because I'm like well I know that I'm
not somebody undercover but like you
know how easily could somebody because I
come over there and people be hanging
out with him all the time like you
always had people over he was slipping
they could well now I never went with
how they never wanted to go to his house
I thought it was just cool that he just
showed up yeah he was a delivery guy for
sure that's why he had that three level
tackle box but I think he didn't invite
me once like he kicked Kiki I just came
from party if you want to go back now
I'm good man yeah she'll here with your
C well he had a done because two people
overdosed in his apartment within the
span of three months and died so that's
bad yeah two people died in his
apartment and then he got raided when he
moved into a warehouse and then he was
done well one of the guys I know D a
comic cuz I know that yeah cuz I know
that the comedian to introduce me to him
he passed away maybe that was a I guess
I don't know if he is a comedy but like
I never really knew their names anyway
whoever these people were and they don't
if you were like go party with all the
community from the Comedy Store in
someone else's house in Burbank and he
had on bathroom stalls outside of his
house
who did though Doug dougie points Dougie
points I know Dougie points ok sounds
like a great guy though it was actually
[ __ ] really cool man we got out of
there as bright as [ __ ] we thought it
was
are you serious yeah this guy headed
whole house bro again with a casino bro
like if there were no clocks you never
knew what time the world the temperature
and the house of perfect Skyler this guy
had like you know trough will you Pete
yeah all started with house like cuz you
know you have a half party people get
[ __ ] up in AP outside yeah portable
water parties outside of the house oh
wow the house was made for party Wow
everybody sign like I'm really glad
never met this guy actually have been
really bad for me I think yeah you and I
never got together actually he told me
is crazy a story one time man like could
them yeah I think so I don't know you're
sober right yeah could live by 13 months
a lot of people on our podcast or
actually one guy he even alerted and
thanked a listener said that I'll be
because of you and Joe Diaz talking
about being sober and you're the prong
he went through man it helped me a lot
and I've been sober now 18 months yeah
wait Joe is not server though yeah yeah
you don't you know no drinking and no
coke just pot and my mother and a sober
is a funny word anything that's [ __ ]
from the earth you know I'm saying we'll
take it down over here at the church yes
sober could be relative but I think also
with something like that it's not as
addictive as the other things that we're
gonna kill you I know what I mean
so I could smoke up I could smoke weed
everyday' do dabs every day and I can't
do mushrooms every day but I love I
don't drink I'm gonna be alright
I don't understand how Anthony Bourdain
you know rest in peace hey store the
crack in heroin addict but he drank
smoked cigarettes and smoke weed but in
the end it didn't work so yeah if they
wonder did he do that yeah succeeded
doing that view that
yeah how do you do it well the meetings
uh yeah I go to meetings have a sponsor
I'm on step four right now and what's
that for you gotta write down you know
it would everything you would get bad
huh not step four is who are you
resenting and then figuring out your
part in it so I'm basically that's where
I'm at right now it's making my list of
like what I resent people agreements you
know places you know just anything
that's been drive me nuts for years and
I'm like oh I'd be doing so much better
if that person didn't screw me over yeah
I mean but but realizing well wait a
minute did they screw you over or where
they human and you were also human and
you both messed up you know like that
sort of thing that's a responsibility
yeah basically yeah the first time with
Tim I still read enough we don't every
second time first time I got sober was
February 23rd 2015 and I did like a
normal rehab I did one in a lebu great
place it's called soba my roommate was
Andy Dick yeah wait did he get checked
in no he was doing like a one where you
he could be gone most the day how long I
was oh that was the one passageways are
patent no that was so low because he
went to go shoot Zoolander too right
yeah it was during the time that was it
that was three years ago yeah three
years ago like right now and you know he
was um he was interesting roommate that
was kind of weird to like wake up to
like you know shake sounds cuz he's
always making shakes he doesn't eat like
solid food he makes shakes you walk in
like what's it say wow I'm making you a
shake and I'm like what's going on he's
like body you need to eat better and
like you would like make like these huge
shakes they're in like I bet what's in
this he's like about like 300 worth of
stuff like a big $300 worth of just like
vitamins and like you know he's exactly
spirulina type [ __ ]
he loves spirulina he's [ __ ] that
[ __ ] but uh yeah I made it a year in
seven months without the steps without a
sponsor just kind of on my own doing it
my own stubborn way and then I crashed
hard dude I
so would you press where is in the
middle of the night I just thrown a 1
year old birthday party for my twins who
are now three well they'll be three in
September and um they I bought a bunch
of alcohol because it's O'Neill okay
this was not like your average one year
old birthday party there was like a
bouncy Mexican one year no honestly it
really was like my wife is Latino so
that's I mean that's why we did it we
had a bouncy house we had we hired cooks
it you know we had the one of those big
taco oh yeah yeah and so we had done the
whole thing and there was leftover
pacific o's and they're in the fridge
man and they said put little water
beating up on them i went in the fridge
to get something to eat and i saw and I
just went [ __ ] it opened it drank it I
was like well I'm relapse might as well
drink another one that's the thought
right there yeah it's not if I stop now
I can start over again
yeah it's oh I've slipped might as well
drink the whole rest of what's in this
fridge but I only have three I only have
three and I didn't get drunk off that
obviously I can't get drunk more beers
there no there was no more in anywhere
in the house yeah but I knew now that I
was relapse she caught me the next
morning
did you know like did you feel like
you'd read those three beers that I'm
here I could stop like what do you mean
like you stopped you can go hit the bars
immediately oh no you're actually that
is kind of the thought was maybe I could
do it this time
yeah yeah maybe I could do it with wine
I'll just drink wine oh that's what we
do we make like we're making any excuse
so there's just you know what I'm low
carbing diet coke and rum yeah yeah
exactly
dude I had I had one thing once where I
was like you know what I'm only gonna
drink at weddings like that was what my
rules for a while because I knew that
there were like seven coming up so
that's pretty good and then I'm like I'm
finding out people are getting married
I'm like dude you should
I give you bro yeah
it sounds like a bad Lionsgate movie the
wedding drinker hilarious how'd your
wife catch you slipping though um she
don't get you slippin now
she walked over to the fridge she got
something out of the fridge addiction
[Laughter]
yeah right a spoof dear that'd be great
yeah we get your crack out your crack
thing you talked about earlier um but um
so we went in the fridge she saw that
they were gone and she walked right over
she was yeah I'll never forget I had a
pillow on top my head I slept on the
couch I made it pretty obvious I'm
sleeping on the couch and there's a
pillow on my head like I'm trying to
like be avoided so she can't smell it
and she wants him like hiding in the
corner with whoa buddy here and so she
goes did you drink last night and I just
didn't want to I said yeah she was okay
okay and I knew I was full mean the oh
okay you don't wanna hear that from the
missus so she loved to take the kids to
school when she came home turned into a
big fight but then I realized I was
relapsed so I just started getting drunk
at night when she go to bed I go to
7-eleven and slam like a 22 ounce of
stone Pale Ale and then I just lame
another one and then I'd buy like five
of those like little airplane Jack
Daniels take them home drink them in the
garage hide them all over the garage and
then you know and then get drunk you
know and I did that for a while and then
it just led to other stuff and Vike it
in and all sorts of stuff it got got the
pills were your thing eventually
big-time big-time yeah to peel back I
remember hiding drinking though no
living with somebody at one time these
people know younger them didn't want me
to drink so I was just like I had all
planned out bro
and I'll find out I had a backpack from
work with a [ __ ] six big-ass beers
damn then I will [ __ ] will see the
Charlotte in a long bath radio radio
loud radio loud
bubble bath just get your [ __ ] up in a
tub bro come on over they'll [ __ ]
struggle for you could've died there bro
so to slip it would be worth it [ __ ]
drunk driving yep
yep it was a bad blow bubble back
most of my gum Oh Donny had to get up
for you the restroom up peanut I do most
of my Nicole makes fun of me because I
take epic bats like three four-hour
baths
epic epic bath I just took a 45-minute
one before I came here
epic by refilling you do that I've never
done that before this is what I do I
fill it up I fill it up and then I just
I turn it off because I like my foot to
be under running hot water so my feet
are like crossed over each other hot
water hits it cascades down my feet and
I just gotta keep going up against yeah
you heard me you [ __ ] her cave I
didn't say it wasn't no I don't know do
your children we like [ __ ] ice high
school we like cold refreshing come out
they're all just like can I ask how that
so you did a different method you talk
to this ibogaine and ayahuasca analyst
how did that feel going to because we've
we've heard actually the first time you
did mushrooms the next morning you felt
like you didn't want to do any drug ever
again you had that feeling three minutes
I didn't want to drink at all right
but because you have urges like that all
the time like throughout like every day
right still you have it every once in a
while you think of it no mention of
Pacific coast yeah I saw your face bro
picture that Pacifica little drops of
coldness Pacifico commercial there when
you drank it I know Maggie for the first
time ever because you remember the first
drink you could feel like all the beer
come down your throat oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're like a vicodin shoe they
just got to land yeah they like Morgan
Freeman boys it all went down here after
it all went downhill after that we never
saw Felipe the same if I fall off the
wagon can you hear that sorry about that
fool oh I know that story that Morgan
Freeman busting those jokes out for
[ __ ] I do like six months that show
was not working dog where'd you do fun
first when you got it I'm like [ __ ]
nobody knows that story so your wife
caught you Jack and I'm right after that
when you were drinking every night every
night when did you go back to the hog
[ __ ] well there's a good story this is
the craziest thing like this is the
craziest thing I've ever done
and Felipe's heard a lot about me so if
I'm saying that you know this is [ __ ]
crazy
so I our guy is gone yeah he's no longer
the guy that deals he's he's no longer
in LA and so I didn't really know a way
to get stuff I'd been out of the game
from it I've been sober a year in seven
months
so I deleted a lot of contacts and I had
no idea what to do so I started going
into the doctor and putting on Academy
award-winning performances that I was in
pain I would limp in I would keep I
would have the limp as I'm walking in
the building in case somebody saw me
through the window I'd have a limp when
I got into the into the waiting room and
I'd even say to the secretary like do
you mind if I take this paperwork and
sit down my foot really hurts you know
and so sweetie absolutely do you need
something to put it up and I'd go with
it you know they'd give me like a an
ottoman to put my foot on you don't mean
and then I get I get pulled in the room
and then I had the nurse come in I put
on a performance for her she's wrong
with your foot nothing's wrong my foot
it's what's wormans performance yeah she
push on certain areas of the foot and I
would wince you know I mean good yeah
blues boy is killing me right now if I
want to do that [ __ ] are you ready this
is the preamble this is not even the
crazy thing that I did you're not even
gonna believe this this is nothing this
I do this kind of stuff in my sleep so
she pushed something foot I'm wincing
doctor comes in puts on the same area I
winced he's like well you know I'll
never forget this he's like you're
definitely gonna need something for the
pain
you to see a podiatrist actually the
other way around because you need to see
a podiatrist you guys put Skylar I got
to tell you man I know you feel like
this but you're gonna need something for
this pain and I was like you think so
like it just got away with it like Annie
goes yeah he goes I'm gonna go ahead and
get you
he's I'm gonna get you five milligram
you know yeah he's like I'm gonna get
you five milligram vicodins and and I
said hey I go I hate to say this because
I don't want to take these because they
just make me nauseous
he's me to Wiggins I have the same
problem I go I can't even he goes let me
tell you I'll give you a little remedy
for that he goes remind me when I'm
leaving I'll tell you how to not get
nauseous and I thank you I go but doc I
remember the last time I took these I
must have a high tolerance because of my
family cuz the five milligrams I just
had to come back in and get tens so can
you just give me tens because I you know
and he just like he's like absolutely he
goes and if that doesn't work we'll have
you come back and get oxy and I'm like
oh like you next week yeah go ahead
schedule him for Tuesday somebody yeah
somebody carrying him brewing here so I
get my prescription I start taking them
I'm not proud of this but this is what
happened I get my prescription I started
taking them and then the next thing you
know my wife had made a deal with me and
she said if if you're gonna be back in
this house this is when I got sober the
first time she was I'm a lot of drug
tests you 24/7 the last year life
there's not one day I can yeah I can
ever walk up to you even if everything's
going great and I'm like my gut instinct
it's completely wrong and you want to
just yell at me you have to pee in a cup
I go deal so she walks up to me cos dude
you can tell when I'm on the [ __ ] I get
loud I get manic I get sweaty I always
tell you guys don't think you can tell
but you know the women they know so I
get loud manic sweaty and you guys are
like well that's how you are right now
but it gets to the ten yeah it gets to
the tens baby I did Sam will tell me Sam
will tell me sober and yes it done
anything but yet everybody's [ __ ]
children and you say wait so I lost him
so um she walks up to me and she goes
remember how you told me that I can drug
test you any day that week oh yeah she
was here you go and she hands me one and
I knew I was [ __ ] because I knew I was
on it I know this is [ __ ] Nicole not
on anything she was cool
then take it I'm like fine and then I go
actually I don't have to pee shoes I
thought you'd say that pulls out the
bottle water from a back pocket hands to
me close the door and our bedrooms to
stay in here don't come out until it's
done so she leaves the room now I'm in
the room I have no idea what to do a
normal person a non addict would just
pee in the cup correct Philippe well is
that what you and I want to do do we
want to [ __ ] get bus the way because
the more you talk about another sort of
thing about how hard dilute that pee in
my mind yeah yeah call a homie and bring
the pee to the [ __ ] window bro well
you have to true your three choices do
it I want a car a pause there the
gardener family wait I'll be on my phone
dog clean weed but you know I didn't
know you had a urinary tract infection
yes they said there's a lot of weeds in
this it's so um you have a choice you do
what you can either pee you can dilute
or you can figure out a way to not pee I
didn't want to pee I want to go through
fair how to dilute I have no way of
[ __ ] my phone was downstairs I didn't
know what yeah so I fall to the floor I
start hitting the ground as hard as I
can I start pulling the sheets off of my
bed I slapped my face I don't know how
many times and got it red I started
sweating I started screaming and I just
started like shaking back and forth dude
I'm Sean Penn in Mystic River at this
point I am performing out of my [ __ ]
ass dude she runs upstairs and the
reason I'm doing this is legit had
kidney stones three times before so I
know what that looks like when you have
kidney stones so she walks in there I'm
going [ __ ] nuts I'm going back and
forth I'm rolie polie back and forth I'm
going insane it's just what's wrong oh
my gosh what's got kidney stones oh my
gosh okay
join me to call 9-1-1 I'm like yes she
starts to grab her phone to call 9-1-1
and I'm like am I really going to waste
an ambulance his time on this am I gonna
like have an ambulance come here when it
could be used for someone that actually
like really needs it am I good am I
gonna go through with this no but I'm
gonna do the next best thing so I told
her I go hang up hang up it's just why
you're in pain I'm gonna try myself I
wouldn't so she's you can't drive
yourself that's danger I'm doing I do a
babe I'm not gonna spend $1500 on an
ambulance to drive me a half a mile away
because it's really not farther the
hospital so she gets me up she
i hobbled like towards the stairs I go
towards the stairs method actor bro
oh yeah I start going down the stairs
I'm screaming in pain you know I'm
passing my [ __ ] and I wanted anyway I
get downstairs and I get right by the
door she gets me the keys and have you
ever seen usual suspects yeah okay you
know at the end when when with a limp
foot the limp and then it goes into the
regular foot you know Keyser Soze comes
walking limp and then it stopped so i'm
thats basically a live version of this
I'm holding my side I'm leaning over I
look like The Hunchback of Notre Dame
I'm screaming like Al Pacino and [ __ ]
Serpico I'm going nuts I get to my
[ __ ] car I get in the car I'm still
leaned over I'm starting the car like
almost like a handicapped person I have
one arm to work with the other arm is
holding my side in pain I Drive I'm
leaning over and I get around the corner
as soon as I round the corner I just
straighten out oh my god okay she can't
see me but then I'm left with a thought
but yeah but now you have to commit to
this and so I don't know if you know why
I did this yet if you can see where this
is going so I Drive to the hospital and
I get there and now I've got to [ __ ]
turn the performance back on and get out
of my car and like start performing on
the way and so now I'm holding my side
again I'm coming into the hospital I get
inside the the waiting room and I scream
out loud I'm in pain I'm in pain and
they get me a bed they put me in the
back and I lie down in a bed and I'm
sitting in the bed and I listened to
come over and look what's going I go
kidney stone the way how do you know I'm
like I've had three like okay and
they're like how much pain you in one to
ten I said eleven and I know that when
you say eleven on one to ten they put
you on dilaudid dilaudid is in the same
class of pill that I was taking so I
knew at this point that if I come home
the next day and she says you never took
that drug test I get to go well I can
take it but it's gonna be dirty because
they put a lot into me at the hospital
and that's why I did it
[ __ ] this is the next Brando bro I'm not
proud of it whatsoever I want to be very
clear on that I'm not it's a story
that's for sure I'm proud of listen to
the story right now yeah when you drugs
but you go all out bro
you don't care you cause like they're
just yeah it's like you turn it to a
second person bro that person is hard
dog but his power for evil this guy last
night in a meeting named Steven he said
um
he said you wake up with two voices in
your head one of them is is talking and
the other one is listening oh my god
never heard of that way but I had not
either and I loved it and the one that's
talking is smooth and he gets what he
wants the pimp and like he tells you
that all your deals are falling apart
people don't like you your wife's not
really into you the only like everything
but yeah like well that's it that's
actually true in my case
I don't know how many pounds the last
anyway so I'm not proud of that story
but I do know that that's not something
I would do again now that I'm sober you
know and you might be like well what's
different this time I got the sponsor
I'm doing the steps I go to the meetings
I have a fellowship I realize from every
meeting how the whole meeting if I don't
show up they all wonder where I am they
check on me like there's like a it's
like a crew I have like an army now
whereas before it's just me being
bullish going I got this I don't even
think I'm an addict I'm just gonna do it
because everyone else thinks I am and
you know do you don't do things like
what I just told you unless you're an
addict nobody [ __ ] does that nobody
it's out of control there's so much work
that goes into it that's a lot of work
and wasted a whole day overnight got
some sweet Hospital through there let me
turn okay but think about it man he
could be other robbing stealing but they
my father putting up performance yeah
it's warrior spirit done in a way I am
robbing and stealing
I'm stealing trust I'm robbing trust I'm
I'm stealing time I'm robbing time I'm
stealing in a sense of my wife and you
are taking a bed from a real sick person
yeah yeah I've thought about that I've
thought about that you know so how did
this this this rehab in Mexico how did
what did it feel like what it was the
experience like and did you feel like
you didn't have urges afterward like it
because I've been interested in this
whole hallucinogenic I absolutely have
urges because you know there's a reason
the term is I'm in recovery you never
recover you know II mean until we get to
the next room you know you're in
recovery you're recovering and so I get
the ER just absolutely like I didn't
have one right now when I said Pacific
go but like if he said my drink like if
Philippe I said you know like oh man and
then I saw a bottle of maker's and ice
cold coke like I I would get that like
little [ __ ] fizz and it makes when
you combine me I know what you're
talking about no I just want to chew on
a railroad ties yes yes that's the stuff
dude but I still get the urges I just
you know an alcoholic you know we don't
have a drinking problem we have a
thinking problem and that's why we drink
because we don't think right and we
don't view things right and so what I
needed to do is go get to the root of
the problem and whereas before all I've
ever treated is the symptoms and
drinking is just a symptom you know it
comes from somewhere else it doesn't you
know you know just love alcohol like
you've found alcohol to cure like I used
alcohol for everything it's something
great happen get [ __ ] up terrible up
and get [ __ ] up like there was nothing
that it would mean if you can't wake up
in the morning get [ __ ] up you can't
sleep get [ __ ] up you know like all
sorts of things general yeah you know
when he was about to win last Comic
Standing I was the most nervous I had
ever been because he had been sober for
maybe eight months mm-hmm and had come
from the worst time we had ever had
together was the year before that and
but when he was about to win last Comic
Standing like the finals I didn't know
who to invite because I didn't know how
he was gonna react if he won and I
didn't know how he's gonna react if he
lost yeah and I was so nervous about
bringing the wrong people you know like
a parent or something it might trigger
something if he was sad about losing or
even happy about winning you either way
it's gonna I was so I was on eggshells
that whole week and you did great but I
was nervous because you had every right
to that's what we do to people but we
don't even know we do that to people I
know it takes
I mean I'm every the way I stay sober is
with moments like I just had right here
with Lisa like hearing that makes me go
I owe my wife one more apology even I've
already done it I love hearing that not
cuz I love that you went through it but
I can't wait to see my wife later and go
you know at least this and share like
what it must have been like for her I go
you must have a lot of moments where
you're so worried whether something goes
good or bad for me I've never heard it
put like that and I guarantee you Nicole
could talk about her experience in front
of you that would make you go I need to
go say sorry to Lisa cause I and that's
why I go to meetings I keep hearing
stuff that makes me go
I did that too I need to go call so and
so friends and family is one thing but
your ladies another thing man oh yeah
partner man cuz that's the [ __ ]
that really [ __ ] knows you're in there
now I owe her so many apologies you know
sometimes only those people can do
something because not only you were
going through your addiction and things
while she was going through something
else with the babies yeah yeah there was
a big thing going I saw you at one time
Lisa and I were having early breakfast
somewhere oh yeah I hop or something
yeah yeah and you came in there and you
get those kids and a young girl and I
was like damn it was just got a little
he was in a good one last night and he
met this girl with two kids another
having breakfast
I saw her the truth yeah when I saw you
there I was like wow this guy's cool
he's like but I don't know you were you
were party but just knew that okay he
met this girl ya know the walk of shame
ain't no and yeah they're having
breakfast together with her kids like a
soldier I don't know you were going
through addiction then oh yeah oh yeah I
mean oh the worst break I started
drinking when I was 14 the way I used to
drink was my parents had a liquor
cabinet and I would go in there and I'd
grab I didn't care which one it was I've
got vodka grab gin it didn't matter but
I grabbed one and I knew that if I took
15 sips within three hours I felt [ __ ]
up and that was at 14 so I would
literally sneak down take a sip it
wasn't a shot so it wasn't like it was
probably a third of a shot so really the
other day I was probably taking
somewhere around you know maybe five six
real shots but at 14 that's a lot yeah
at 14 what made you want to go do that
did you want to get [ __ ] up or you
wanted to try like see how it tasted
well I get so that it will circle back
because it'll answer the other question
you asked which was you know you said
what was different about this Mexico
time when I went down there they they
have you do one night of ibogaine one
big hit of DMT and six nights of
ayahuasca yeah absolutely night oh yeah
two nights maybe
what are you doing nights well okay so
with ayahuasca you have a shaman
you have a group of people you there's a
diet called diantha and you take you eat
certain things and you also don't eat
certain things for about a week leading
up you're supposed to eliminate sex and
media and television from your diet for
a certain amount of day so that your
eyes are and your whole palate is
basically clear and your brains not
spinning too much there's no caffeine
there's no sugar I mean it's it's a
[ __ ] it's not a fun it's like
well if I can't eat sugar I at least
want to watch TV and if I can't watch TV
I want to eat something like it's sucks
dude and you're also trying to kick
drugs and alcohol so you're basically
just sitting there playing with a paddle
ball in [ __ ] Mexico yeah I mean it's
like [ __ ] you know and so um table
tennis champ yeah we didn't have table
tennis but we did have a paddle ball so
um they love paddle ball down there I
don't [ __ ] know what that's all about
but um so you sit down or you lie down
and you have your own space and your to
write a journal before you start about
your intentions what do you want to find
out what do you want to go in it's
because getting sober is an inside job
right it's not out has nothing to do
with Trump nothing to do with your wife
nothing with anything it's an inside job
and so I had to write out my intentions
and my intention for my first night was
why do I get [ __ ] up I just wanted to
make it simple why the [ __ ] do I get
[ __ ] up and I saw a lot of crazy stuff
man you drink this tea and it goes down
like sludge like it is not taste good
and it feels weird going down and
there's this guy singing these songs and
this impossible to understand language
and you don't know what he's singing
about and they're beating on a drum and
like it takes about an hour to kick in
sort of like ecstasy you know so and
then when it kicks it were you an e guy
or never now once that one's what about
you I've only done I've only smoked weed
and done mushrooms and acid occasionally
but never rolled bro it's a white boy
thing isn't it what is I knew a lot of
pools that used to do it but I just was
afraid because I heard some [ __ ] that'll
burn the [ __ ] hole in your brain yeah
kids 2pk said he and his friends were
all into that was it about people being
so scared about something having their
brain but then when you hear that
alcohol and smoking will [ __ ] up your
heart I'm like oh I'll do that like for
the second is your brain is that long I
don't know man it's weird I think
[ __ ] with the whole [ __ ] you know you
know yeah so once I got on it weird
things start to happen I
lying down and this may sound strange
but I felt this hand pushing on my head
and pushing me down like as hard as
possible and it was mother ayahuasca
because it's a female spirit that visits
you and she was pushing me down
basically saying listen [ __ ]
because you never do and then my grandma
came and my grandma said you're not
being one of us let us get to work and I
started crying because to hear my
grandma's voice to smell her to feel her
and know that she can see everything all
these things that we wonder like can
they see us or do we go to another realm
other angels do they see over us I now
know no matter what anybody says to me
they absolutely are still connected to
us because she knew things about me and
she was talking to me about you know
what I've done and why I'm the way that
I am and I mean so much of it would take
so long to explain but in a nutshell one
of the best things that happened for me
was I rely see I wasn't that kid a lot
of people I go you must have not have
gotten a lot of attention I got tons of
attention there was no problem I mean
parents were both there they're still
married my sisters were there there was
I was not some neglected kid that's like
oh my God look at me it was more this
sense of my family was so enigmatic and
such a kooky cast of characters all of
them uncles great I mean there's nobody
in my family that you'd meet and go well
that person's boring they're all
eccentric crazy fucked-up hilarious
awesome imperfect people and I just felt
like because of that I need it to be
like the loudest like I just I just felt
like I wanted to compare you fine you're
yeah I ever izing about yeah and so like
you know the biggest thing I learned was
I started doing that at a young age
because there was a lot of tragedy in my
family I had one grandma not wear a
seatbelt right where the four or five
had sunset and she was out here living
as a writer for a little bit and she got
flung through a window through the
windshield and couldn't walk hear or see
out of her left eye for the rest of her
life so I only knew her as a deaf can't
see very well not walking grandmother
and then my other set of grandparents
died instantly in Kansas City in 1982
when this big sky walk collapsed at a
Hyatt Hotel and 143 people died it's the
biggest architectural accident in
America of all time and my grandparents
were crushed by concrete and so there
was all this pain around me when I was
little and so on ayahuasca I learned
like I'd wanted to become a clown for
everybody you know I wanted to like
really take care of it he make everybody
laugh and like be this person and so
that's why I started becoming the way
that I became and then when my parents
moved me at 15 that's the last thing
I'll say about this is when they moved
me from Missouri to Michigan I lost all
my friends I lost all my theater friends
my baseball friends my best friends
everybody I grew up with and I was a
runt I was skinny I was like really
awkward I was just weird and I couldn't
get friends for the life of me when I
moved so I just found the funnier I
became you know the more people wanted
to hang out with me and then when I saw
kids drinking I decided well I'm gonna
drink better and it'd be just I'm just a
competitive person so my competitive
nature just became just like I compete
it when I was young amongst these kooky
characters I decided I'm gonna compete
amongst drinkers and then I just became
you know you just become known for
something like oh you have little have
little inside jokes on this pocket I
know your guys this [ __ ] like I like so
you when you become known for something
and you find all that works we get a lot
of retweets with this [ __ ] get
down a 40 dog shot oh no I'm just saying
about you're known for something else
when all that [ __ ] so so what happened
was I would get to parties and people
like all up Skyler's here you know [ __ ]
the Royals yeah I was known for
something like this was cool right
superhero like you know that I'm Captain
America I don't know cape and she
brought the party yeah dude no spotlight
I'm the Hulk I'm the green one you know
the party dude say what Giroux coupie
was another party dude [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah and so I just started realizing
that like you know I did all I had to do
with my competitive nature my wanting to
be heard nature my obsessive be you know
and just wanting to the [ __ ] doesn't
want to be loved you mean yeah and so I
became this character and slowly over
time I've realized people of constantly
said Skylar's not how you think if you
really just knew him he's actually cool
but the people that don't know me that
well and just know the stories like no I
already is a piece of [ __ ] and sorry
yeah I started realizing I'm like wait a
minute
am i me or am i a character and I know
that part of Hollywood is you do become
a character like Harrison Ford isn't
probably exactly how we think he is like
that's like that's something
become when the cameras are on and
that's fine but I was doing it 24/7 I
was doing it all the time there was no
when that when the call time would
rapping like let's keep going because I
gotta I'm high now like I gotta keep
like I got it not even necessarily high
high like smoking weed I I would just be
like manic high and I'd be like what the
set would be done and everybody be
leaving and I'd want to keep the party
going and so since I can't go create the
set that made me this high like this I
can't get all the cool actors and the
lights and the fun and the and the
energy and the studio execs and whatever
let's go to a bar cuz I know how to
control that I know how to run that and
so we go to a bar and I didn't fight the
crew guys and the actors and then here
we are and then I get too [ __ ] up and
before you know it like this before
uber I was just getting in a car driving
on people like I don't like that guy
like he look at him he's [ __ ] hammer
and he's getting in a car and driving
away and like a foot that dude's cool
man you know wanting to keep the
adrenaline going after everyone party
bro and people want to go home go home
[ __ ] that you gonna eat right now
it's like going it's you know throughout
the party a party for two nights
straight and mofo couple of us that was
making that sandwich man party by it's
like getting sent to sleep as a little
kid you don't want to go to bed dog
that's exactly it
I'm stealing that for its today that's
exactly I just didn't want to go to bed
and it was 24/7 and then it like it's it
crept into phone calls like conference
calls and IBM calls with other promoters
or like producers and actors and just
like I just started this nature this
competitive nature wouldn't stop and
this is obsessiveness and I would just
invade people's privacy and and throw
people's face in the mud if they made
mistakes when working with me like I
just be I became a [ __ ] monster dude
a [ __ ] monster so yeah man I just you
you were holding that Collishaw man what
is this food oh oh you remember that
[ __ ] oh my god and I said you work also
with that other crazy my father
sometimes so great hunt no no okay Oh DJ
yeah yeah
yet that they created the earth Colli
Colli soul yeah always drinking bro
always always always a good one yeah I
got banned from the Laugh Factory for
seven years once because yeah because in
2007 I was almost got my biggest part
ever at the time at least I was gonna be
in Alvin and the Chipmunks and it was
the Jason what's the guys Jason Lee
Jason Lee so he's the lead and then he's
got the three chipmunks right and when
they get signed to a label there was
like a label president like a like a
really like you know smarmy you know
slick you know kind of like Ari Gold
before Ari Gold like it was like a an
agent character right I guess not before
I got all her gold was on the air at
that time and so it was down to three
people and I know this gonna sound
really funny cuz this really proves they
had no idea who they want it was down to
David Cross George Lopez and me shut up
you get you guys were together but you a
Mexican and then [ __ ] me you didn't
get a George right no absolutely
right now man not even later later man I
mean [ __ ] host you know we had the
Hollywood Bowl and [ __ ] it [ __ ] you
gotta say it [ __ ] or it's not George
okay dude you're good dude
so next thing you know I checked was on
its way to my house I was gonna get like
I think 80 grand I was like I never
heard of that amount of money my love
the big row of it I was [ __ ] pomp
dude like it was a lead role in the
movie it might've been my first studio
lead the own Amy and I had bit parts but
nothing like that and so literally the
contracts about to get carried to my
house I don't know what happened but
story goes it's something like David
Cross came down and his price and
decided he would do it for less and they
got him in a steel and you know he was a
name and I wasn't and you know my show
had just been cancelled and his hadn't
and that's just how it went so I got
pissed and I started getting drunk and I
got blacked out I start drinking about 3
p.m. and I took a cab actually for once
I took a cab to the Laugh Factory it was
a show with Dane finesse Mitchell and
Jeremy hots and a couple other people
and I get in a cab I go over there
I get on stage I'm the first comic up on
the light up and I'm blacked out and no
one knew I was blocked up he's like I
kept a chill but I get up on stage and
there's an old guy in the front row yeah
there's an old guy in the front row this
was right before Michael Richards got
recorded saying the n-word and all that
stuff there if you remember that of
course man and so there's an old guy in
the front row sitting by himself and I
guess I started doing crowd work on him
but it wasn't funny like it was just
mean like Oh where's your wife did she
die and you live alone now and like he's
like he's like yeah actually she died a
year and a half ago and liked it so the
whole rooms looking like dude leave the
[ __ ] old guy alone you know
and on my Oh so when are you gonna die
like just terrible at God work terrible
clearly from someone that hates them
yeah yeah and so I get off stage and I
go upstairs and finesse Mitchell held me
up against the wall and this is a really
nice pussycat of a guy but people like
that if you get them in the wrong place
then you know that means that they've
been holding back a lot for maybe three
years and this is their chance to blow
up Vanessa Minh yesterday
yeah man Skylar I need to talk to you
right now I think and so you had me up
against the wall and he just said you
you cannot do that man you just derailed
this show and then somebody to get up
there and get this show going back and
they [ __ ] bombed all cuz of you and
Danes behind him yelling at me and
everyone's yelling at me and I don't
remember a lot of it but you know I was
like four five give him the super finger
back five and so I got kicked out and
they banned me for seven years I'm back
now I've been there for a long time I'm
not you know and me and Jamie are great
but yeah buddy I was just gonna ask you
a quick question to see how you did it
crossing the line as an extra and
talking of the to the actors how did you
do how did you do that how did you cross
that line
you're not never supposed to cross as a
guy in movies I would just no I would
make sure to not plan anything I wanted
to say they know when you've planned it
they know when you've looked up a story
and said oh I heard you or did you
really like the San Francisco Giants
it's like they know that the night
before you did homework and that you
thought of a conversation to have and if
someone did that they know that you're
only doing it because you want to get
close to them so I'd wait for something
in the moment if I saw something spill
next to Ryan Reynolds I'd make a joke
about that because then it's like
alright well that just happened I'm
clearly not trying to buddy-buddy up I'm
just like [ __ ] talking to you like a
real person and like I would just keep
it like that and
for you know what I'd see them kind of
get closer to me go hey man you're
really funny by the way they would okay
go and we'd start talking you know but I
never went up to somebody and said no I
asked that true I pulled a couple you
said that you you told me you get all of
you you told me you get a little family
I can get fan boy to do i there was a
couple actors that I like walked right
up to I scared the [ __ ] out of Harrison
Ford at the 41 premiere that Jackie
Robinson movie I like walked up to
Harrison Ford and like I think he
immediately thought he's about to get
raped like it was [ __ ] and he
probably was he was doing I love
Harrison Ford you get that way though he
did it he doesn't sometimes the last
time I saw you do it wasn't we were at
the pumpkin patch and Aubrey Plaza was
though that actor do from with Criminal
Minds criminal yeah the cheekbones
looking dude anyway uh Felipe just shows
up Aubrey Plaza but he was he just
yelled out her name like Kramer I saw
Jennifer Love Hewitt was and I walked up
to her please tell me you said all three
names jennifer Love Hewitt Jennifer yeah
she was there on the day with some loser
and she's been around say that my
friends married or and invited to my
comedy show Wow oh yeah
the worst one was but I'm working at
Dodger Stadium making hot dogs and I was
peeing and I looked at a side of me pee
next to me with John Ritter he was
hiding with it had his beard
where was this Dodger Stadium and I'm
standing next to him and I wanted a John
Ritter juice company I started humming
the song P you did not therefore
greatest peanuts and SKU and went to the
other side bro now he stopped peeing
held it and then went to was a pee all
the way to the end didn't say anything
your [ __ ] no idea nervously my friend
with sometimes you can sometimes you can
make a joke
and like really get them like and get
them to be like really like you and so
Bruce Willis was at the Hollywood Bowl
and my friend Zach and my dad we were
there watching the whole the Rolling
Stones and so I don't have you ever been
a Rolling Stones show but the Keith
Richards always does like two solo songs
and that's usually when everybody gets
up to pee because that they're not good
you know and so Bruce Willis is in the
bathroom peeing and my friend Zach is
right next to him in Saks one of the
funniest people you'll ever meet in your
whole life and he just sitting there he
just has no shame he'll say anything to
anybody and he literally turns and makes
that joke he goes yell BW what he's like
he's like you're just like nated [ __ ]
you hear Keith Richards solo songs time
to take a piss and he starts a little
dying dude Zach said BW yeah that should
kill me but you just like me yeah what
stuff was your Instagram your social
media Instagram is the Schuyler stone
and people smell Schuyler wrong all the
time
it's not a arts er so it's the S Kyl er
stone and it's the same thing on Twitter
and you know Scholes coming up yeah my
next [ __ ] what is this release by the
way this right Thursday night but it's
live right now in video ok this well not
this Thursday but the next Thursday June
21st I have a killer show at The Comedy
Store my show is called comedy rocks it
will sell out so get tickets it's Todd
Barry Natasha Leggero Marc Maron Nick
Kroll and Garfunkel & Oates
so it's gonna be badass show Thursday
June Thursday June 21st 7:30 p.m. and
you have that show twice a month yeah
every other Thursday yep so full
upcoming show Schaumburg Illinois this
week Jul 15 2013 at the Schomburg improv
outside Chicago El Paso Texas June 22nd
at the Plaza theater
San Antonio Texas June 23rd second show
at the Tobin Center officials are just
about sold out Orlando Florida June 28th
July 1st at Orlando improv Hermosa
California July 17th comedy
magic one night only check out Philippe
WorldCom slashed or four are coming
shows yeah man
reality Chicago this week with you and
then please roll out all the things very
very very much for Skylar storm being a
great guest
hell yeah this myself are your recovery
broke goddamn crazy a story
it's crazy thank you whoo that Jam that
act acted to the [ __ ] here with the
main stone himself or so fool